there was a girl I had a huge crush on
when I was a kid and she wear this like
cotton candy perfume and every time I
would smell it I would like think about
her and then a couple years later my
sister started wearing it and that that
me up
oh this must kind of lemony with a hint
of rose I'm not mad at that that smells
kind of like candy I think it smells
like you would clean with this I don't
know man
every overview smells like they smell
like mom's to me you know in the
bathroom when someone just blew it up
and they Febreze it kind of getting that
hint right now I thought I could smell
it on a guy to still be like alright
this works for you I can't imagine
getting whiff of this at a bar and being
like Oh who's that this is more like oh
[ __ ] mom came to pick me up cuz I cut to
drugs I don't know what gold smells like
but this isn't what I picture gold
smelling like this one kind of smells
like marshmallows and vodka birthday
cake this one smells like off mosquito
spray I could see a Kardashian wearing
this one but not Kim it's like a Chloe I
could do without gold I think playfully
spirited charmingly fun a bubbly floral
fruity that radiates the sunny and
sparkling energy basically just
described me it's like sweet and floral
it's like a honey flower smells a lot
like high school this could be like a
really good air freshener for after you
make Asha doobs I like this what this
does Daisy I think is the perfect name
for this it's just like a good walk in
the park if I were a girl this is what I
would wear this is like Jewish girl from
New York is probably all about this [ __ ]
now this one I like I would be okay if
my girlfriend was wearing this this is
this is a nice smell I feel actually
knows what she's doing it like in the
bedroom and I get first-year Intimidator
you're like I don't know if I could keep
up with her and then she's like no I got
you I'm gonna teach you if you love
taking nyquil this is the perfume for
you somebody wore this it was hugging me
I'd be like you smell nice you smell
good I'm still at Daisy level but I hope
someday I could be a la fiesta jazz
tomboy tomboy to do no wrong oh that is
that is awful what is that no get this
one away smells like a churro died it
smells like uh an old fashioned like if
an orange had an [ __ ] this one
actually smells like a dude unisex I
feel like no sex should wear this one
I'm a mad at it I figured with this one
I would wear this one whether it was Tom
Ford or not who would wear this I hope
if you're watching and you wear this I'm
so sorry we can never be you always
notice when people smell bad you don't
necessarily notice when people smell
good and so I think that's a good reason
to invest into a nice clone to be fair
you can probably just go down to Rite
Aid